mehr live zugeschaltet ist jetzt der
moderator und journalist sehr akten der
sendung aktenzeichen xy
rudi cerne hallo herr zähne jahr in
ihrer sendung gestern abend wurde zum
ersten mal bekannt dass es einen
tatverdächtigen gibt das bag hat sie
aber bis zur ausstrahlung alles
strengstens geheim zu halten warum
na ja man sollte einfach mit dieser
abgesprochenen mit dieser abgesprochenen
situation ganz zentral auf die leute
zugehen
die gefahr besteht ja dass so was im
vorfeld verbessert und dass dadurch auch
durch geringere bekanntgaben
ein mitwisser unter umständen gewarnt
werden könnte und dadurch spuren
verwischt werden könnten und den wollte
man vorbeugen und im allgemeinen ist
dieses vorhaben ja jetzt aufgegangen ich
meine sie merken ja die resonanz am tag
nach der sendung ist ganz enorm und
dadurch kommt natürlich immer neue und
weitere hinweise ein wie wir hoffen sie
haben den feier von anfang an ihrer
sendung aktenzeichen xy begleitet was
haben sie persönlich für erinnerungen an
den fall maddie na ja das kommt immer
wieder auch vor einem monat gab es ja
auch schon wieder eine aktuelle
zusammenfassung also einige jahre danach
2013 waren kate und gerry mccann live
bei uns in der sendung und wenn man ja
diese aussage anwenden kann vom
schicksal gezeichnet dann trifft das auf
kate mehr kennen wie oft keine andere
person zu die ich im laufe meiner
laufbahn als moderatorin zeichen
kennengelernt habe man hat der dame der
mutter von mel erkennen damals wirklich
diese körperliche belastung regelrecht
angemerkt man hat das regelrecht gespürt
die hoffnung blieb bis zuletzt ich denke
die hoffnung wird heute auch noch sein
wir müssen festhalten an dieser stelle
es gibt noch keine leiche es gibt auch
keinen dringenden tatverdacht gegen den
verdächtigen sondern zunächst mal nur
einen verdacht es gibt indizien es gibt
hinweise es gibt tipps aber es gibt
keinen beweis
es gibt keine leiche und es gibt kein
geständnis und so lange müssen die
ermittler weiter arbeiten das ist jetzt
eine sisyphus-arbeit aber sind das sehr
sorgfältig und ich habe den eindruck die
schlinge zieht sich immer weiter zu sie
haben das interview mit den eltern
gerade angesprochen es dann ein weiteres
interview in ihrer sendung mit den
eltern von maddie geplant
bislang ist noch nichts geplant wir
müssen einfach mal abwarten wir tauchen
hier regelmäßig mit unserer sendung wo
ist mein kind sie zeigen ja auch gerade
wieder bilder aus dieser sendung im zdf
auf mal schauen vielleicht machen wir
das im nächsten jahr auch wieder und wir
wissen aus der zuschauerresonanz dass
die zuschauer sehr großen wert darauf
legen was passiert eigentlich in diesen
fällen und es wäre natürlich eine
möglichkeit aber das hängt ganz von den
eltern ab darüber noch einmal zu reden
ich weiß gerry mccann hat mir das damals
sehr eindringlich gesagt erzählte
solange der beweis nicht erbracht ist es
meine tochter tot ist habe ich das recht
weiterhin zu glauben dass sie noch lebt
also im moment gehen die ermittler
natürlich davon aus dass mit einem
erkennen nicht mehr lebt bei dem
verdächtigen handelt es sich um einen
brutalen vergewaltiger um einen
gefährlichen sexualstraftäter also das
muss in betracht gezogen werden aber
nichtsdestotrotz ich weiß das aus
anderen fällen wenn in etwa eine mutter
zu einem konter und sagt der ferne auch
wenn meine tochter wenn man angehöriger
jetzt tot ist
ich hätte dann endlich eine gewissheit
und ein grab und einen grabstein an dem
ich trauern könnte ja herr cern sie
haben gerade das angesprochene
verdächtige ist ein brutaler
vergewaltiger wir haben jetzt auch ein
foto von ihm was ging in ihnen vor als
das foto zum ersten mal gesehen haben
naja man man man sieht den tätern man
sieht ihnen die brutalität mit der sie
vielleicht einfach oder mit der die
anfall begehen nicht an das ist ein
mensch wie du und ich rein äußerlich
aber was da in dem kopf vorgeht das kann
man natürlich nicht beurteilen
vielen dank herr zähne für das gespräch
und für die auch sehr persönliche
einblicke zu dem fall maddie